حتى
قبل أن تبدأ في عام 2023 ، هيئ نفسك
للنجاح في العام الجديد من خلال التركيز
على صحتك الآن بدلاً من تغيير واحد كبير
يبدأ بالأساسيات ،
17 يناير هو متوسط ​​اليوم الذي
يكسر فيه الأمريكيون قراراتهم للعام الجديد ،
لذا اجعل خطوات صغيرة واجعلها
صغيرة.  يقول الدكتور
ستيفن كوباتسكي من Mayo Clinic
أن التغييرات المستدامة في قائمة المراجعة الصحية لنهاية العام
يجب أن تكون تحديد مواعيد زيارات العافية
مع مقدم الرعاية الأولية الخاص بك ، والتحقق من
مستوى الكوليسترول في الدم لديك ، وإذا كان
معرضًا للخطر ، فسيتم فحصه من أجل فحوصات مرض السكري
الروتينية لأمراض السرطان.
مفتاح للحفاظ على صحة جيدة وتسليح
نفسك بالمعرفة من خلال جعل
صحتك وظيفة بدوام جزئي ، احصل على جهاز قياس
ضغط الدم في المنزل لديك ربطه
بجهاز iPhone أو الهاتف الذكي الخاص بك
حتى يسجل الضغوط تعرف على الأدوية الخاصة بك ،
احتفظ بقائمة على  يعرف هاتفك الذكي
ما هي سبب تناولك
لها ، وما الآثار الجانبية التي
يقولها kopetsky لاختيار يوم أو أسبوع
للتركيز على ساعة صحية  قليلاً قليلاً ، لذلك ليس الأمر
صعبًا ، فما هو مهم كيف أن ما
تأكله بعد ذلك هو مقدار
النشاط البدني الذي تمارسه بعد ذلك ، وهو
نومك الذي يعد أحد عوامل الخطر المنسية
وأخيراً تلقي التطعيم ،
لم يفت الأوان بعد للحصول على لقاح الإنفلونزا أو
تحديث covid-19  إذا كنت
مؤهلاً ، يقول kopetsky أن هذا يمكن أن
يقلل فعليًا من خطر الإصابة بأمراض القلب والأوعية
الدموية عندما نصاب بالأنفلونزا أو
نشعر بالرغبة في الحصول على الكثير من الالتهابات في
أجسامنا وهذا يؤدي بعد ذلك إلى مشاكل
في بطانة شراييننا
حيث تبدأ  لمنع
حدوث جلطات دموية يمكن أن تؤدي إلى نوبة قلبية
أو سكتة دماغية للصحة دقيقة أنا آندي
جاثر